hey guys today i'm going to do a
tutorial for you on how to get better
sound
um
sound recording quality out of your
youtube videos if you don't have a very
good built-in microphone
this is for people with i guess laptops
who haven't bought an external
microphone yet and plan on doing
tutorials like i am um
i
have not bought a microphone so i'm
using the the ones built in to my webcam
so here's how i give it a little boost
when i'm not very loud or when uh i need
the little
um
just need the boost so you right click
on your sound
and
hit recording devices
it'll open up this window as i speak you
can see this little uh this little
volume recorder going up and down so if
i get closer to the mic it's louder if i
get further from the mic it gets softer
so you want to double click on it and
click microphone and now click levels
and in levels you want to if you want to
apply a microphone boost that is what
i'm doing i have a microphone boost
right now applied of 10 decibels you hit
the apply button hit ok
and that's all you have to do no extra
software needed it's built into windows
vista and i'll look into this on windows
xp but uh
that is how i get better sound recording
quality out of my videos without buying
an external microphone purchasing or
downloading software
very simple so um
if you like this tutorial go ahead and
subscribe i'm doing a lot more videos
now so uh peace out